ladies and gentlemen this is corrosion I
fajir and I am very excited to show you
the new features of Lux render version
1.5 lakhs render is a physically based
rendering that generates photorealistic
images from scenes that are created in
3d modeller programs here you can see
the geometry of a scene in a modular
program after we have the geometry of
objects we assign material models to
them
and here you can see what a
photorealistic rendering does with it at
Lux render we are privileged to have so
many incredibly skilled artists using
our system and creating stunning scenes
such as these ones so about the new
release there is just so much meat in
this one very excited to tell you all
about it ready let's get started
first off lacks render now uses a
microkernel based architecture that can
compile and render super high-resolution
images like this in about five minutes
the resolution of this image is higher
than 4k it is so detailed that even if
we zoom in this match
it still looks remarkably crisp the new
biased path tracer engine has a variety
of new features
examples include tiled rendering
radiance clamping to reduce Firefly
noise visibility for indirect rays and
many others in short the new biased path
engine allows fine control over the
sampling process giving you a more
powerful and flexible algorithm locks
render now supports adaptive rendering
which means that it will automatically
find and concentrate on noisy regions of
the image it won't waste your resources
on regions of the image that are already
done the new Intel Embree based
accelerator is between 20 to 50 percent
faster than the previous technique for
building acceleration structures this
helps the renderer to minimize the
amount of time spent with intersecting
rays of light against geometry blacks
render now natively supports a new light
source type called in laser light no
more hacking with tubes and IES profiles
you can now create unique artistic
effects by slicing scenes in half with
the new arbitrary clipping playing
feature the new point in this feature
allows using surface curvature
information in material
this powerful mechanic can be used to
create worn wooden edges moss in rock
crevices and many others of mystical
effects with the no volume priority
system it is finally really easy to
correctly and intuitively render
overlapping volumes hair strands
primitives are now supported look at
these incredible examples there's going
to be lots of fun to be had with this
one
exporting meshes is now up to sixteen
times faster we have a completely new
Lux render plugin for 3d studio max it's
still early in development but it's
definitely worth checking out
let us know what you think about it and
the icing on the cake we have a new
volumetric emission system that supports
fire and many other kinds of glowing
volumes here in the video you see
nothing less than a textured
heterogeneous volume with animated
colors love the demo scene look on this
one and please note that this is not
everything in fact not even close to
what lacks render one-point-five has to
offer I have put the forum post with all
the changes and the new features in the
description box check it out we invite
you to come and give it a try we also
have a sim repository where you can
download a collection of really tasty
scenes to get you started and if you're
stuck or if there's anything we can help
you with just jump on the forums and let
us know we'll be more than happy to have
you as a member of our friendly
community or if you have created
something great with Lux render let us
know so we can marvel at your work
together thanks for watching and I'll
see you in the forums Cheers